les accueillants noté rien du samedi 20
heures ce soir jean et marcel nuss
bonsoir
alors
dit il
après avoir connu le monde de libertin
et avoir été escort-girl vous êtes
devenu accompagnantes sexuels pour
personnes handicapées vous marcel
atteint d'une maladie génétique à vous
avez passé toute votre vie sur un
fauteuil et un jour vos chemins se sont
croisés vous êtes tombé follement
amoureux l'un de l'autre et vous vous
êtes mariés voilà
alors gilles et marcel nuss re bonsoir
jill commençant par vous vous êtes né le
24 octobre 1984 a pointé alto dans la
banlieue sud de santiago du chili à
l'âge de trois mois vous êtes adopté par
un couple de parisiens père ingénieur
mère directrice du marketing dans un
groupe international vous grandissez à
rueil malmaison dans un confort matériel
et affectif total wima adopté désirer
les démarches d'adoption sont très
longues donc forcément la petite
princesse qui manquent de rien voilà
mais à l'adolescence vous vous sentez
pas très à l'aise dans votre tête et
dans votre milieu social vous refusez la
vie rangée qui vous attend à 14 ans vous
abandonnez l'école pour un cap2
mécanique oui je suis parti de chez mes
parents à 15 ans est donc là vous partez
pour suivre une bande de jaunards oui
j'ai une vie de bohème ce qu'on appelle
une vie de bohème j'ai vécu dans la rue
est connue le monde de la nuit
j'ai fait mes propres expériences
marcel vous êtes né le 13 février
azaïs paul shy'm 13 salles près de
strasbourg père menuisier mère femme au
foyer
et à huit mois une forte fièvre vous
cloue au lit
huit mois d'hospitalisation plus tard la
médecine se déclare impuissante sur
votre cas on parle de poliomyélite de
myopathie en fait vous êtes atteint
d'amyotrophie spinale
une maladie congénitale évolutive vous
êtes bien renseigné à partir de 5 ans
c'est le fauteuil oui à 9 ans vous êtes
incapable de vous asseoir son corset
mais vous êtes scolarisés dans l'école
du village je pense que ça va beaucoup
et dif 1
ça m'a permis de mûrir
d'affronter la vraie vie à 15 ans
malheureusement vous êtes trop faible
pour aller à l'école
et entre 16 et 17 ans vous perdez
l'usagé de vos membres supérieurs à 19
en arrêt respiratoire
ou partez à l'hôpital pour huit jours
huit jours de coma vous y resterez six
ans
ça c'est en fait le vrai début de la vie
ouais c'est très paradoxal
il a fallu que je
frôle la mort
on est vraiment allé vite
alors deal à l'adolescence vous
découvrez c'est normal notre sexualité
vous découvrez vous est bisexuelle
mais c'est avec des garçons que vous
vivrez deux grandes histoires d'amour 5
ans et 6 ans dépendants ces deux
histoires vous avez été extrêmement
fidèles puis à ces garçons toujours
mais après chacune de ces expériences
vous profitez de votre célibat et vous
découvrez le monde libertin vous dites
je me suis beaucoup amusé oui faire
l'amour avec des inconnus j'ai un truc
qui vous plaisent et oui vous pouvez
tout à fait j'ai
vu que j'avais aucun a priori à coucher
avec soit des hommes soient des femmes
des inconnus c'est là que vous décidez
d'en faire votre métier et vous devenez
escort-girl
marcel vous vous découvrez la sexualité
à travers les confidences des
infirmières parfois c'est hyper chose
qu'elle vous raccourci hyper chaud mais
si vous êtes confident de ces dames
malheureusement quand vous voulez leur
raconter vos histoires elle refuse de
vous écouter en général elles partent en
courant et oui alors le jour où une
infirmière découvre que vous demandez
elle quitte la chambre est la honte de
ce à quoi rien fait
à l'époque j'étais tellement mal
que j'ai fait exprès demander leur aide
harry d'accord a pris montrer que
bach agitée dans paris
et puis un jour à l'hôpital vous
rencontrez une jeune infirmière de 21
ans gaby
une amitié se noue et bientôt vous
découvrez que c'est de l'amour
contre l'avis général cette gaby va vous
installer chez elle elle démissionne de
l'hôpital pour s'occuper de vous 24
heures sur 24 formidable cédant monture
amoureuse et humaine
alors avec gaby vous faites l'amour
vous marier oui vous faites deux enfants
et oui qui sont en très bonne santé
elles vont très bien tuiles ont très
bien alors t-il à ce moment là vous êtes
escort girls pour le fun dites vous et
un jour un homme vous appelle pour
s'offrir vos services il vous avoue
qu'il est tétraplégique
cloué sur un fauteuil et vous répondez
oui alors on a tous nos problèmes parce
que jugée dit exactement et là au lieu
d'y passer une heure 1 vous y passer
l'après midi
cet homme va devenir un client régulier
et vous permettre de découvrir une chose
très importante vous trouvez à votre vie
une utilité sociale oui à ce moment là
j'ai donc eu cette prise de conscience
et je sentais effectivement que dans ces
rencontres
il se jouait vraiment autre chose je
sentais que j'apportais quelque chose
aux clients valide mais l'aja portait
beaucoup plus également beaucoup plus et
vous devenez assistantes sexuelles vous
dites la prostitution classique c'est
pour le fun
l'assistance sexuelle c'est pour la
cause
alors c'est vrai mais par exemple la
scène d'intouchable ou françois accusés
se fait masser des oreilles par une
prostituée est vrai c'est le désir des
places les zones érogènes évidemment oui
alors marcel en 2001 après 20 ans de vie
commune vous séparer de gaby sauf que
avec 900 euros par mois vous ne pouvez
payer que trois heures par jour
d'accompagnement c'est ça alors là pour
éviter l' institution spécialisée
les deux formidables vous remuer ciel et
terre et grâce à votre combat la loi
change vous obtenez les moyens d'engager
des personnes pour s'occuper de vous 24
sur 24 vous allez voir ségolène royal
quoi je lui ai fait
deux grèves de la santé n'a pas apprécié
et en plus j'ai médiatisé
et celle d'un l'origine
d'une vraie révolution sociale c'est ça
sera
légalisé en 2005 voilà
là dessus vous écrivez votre biographie
vous écrivez des essais vous écrivez de
la poésie et surtout vous commencez
marcel à parcourir la france pour donner
des conférences consacrées aux
handicapés à leurs problèmes à commencer
par le sexe jetteront la souffrance
de ces personnes handicapées
sont dans la solitude qui sont
mal médian de l'institution
tous les braves a envie
de leur apporter un peu du bien je pars
du principe que j'ai les capacités
de lise et des
donc six mois de l'année
samak d'ouvrir les portes
alors devenu une référence dans le
domaine et ses activités dont vous amène
à rencontrer des fans marion je suis dit
lily enfin on peut dire d un tourneur
marcel ce que je trouve très drôle
aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on me demande comment je fais
alors que il ya 30 ans
j'étais très handicapée jill à la même
époque
le sexe chez les handicapés devient pour
vous une raison d'être vous lisez les
bouquins de marcel
vous regardez les vidéos de marcel sur
youtube johnny une groupie oui j'étais
fan de marcel j'espérais un jour pouvoir
le rencontrer ouais
et marcel donc un jour un ami sexologue
vous recommande gilles pour un handicapé
en détresse et c'est comme ça que vous
vous rencontrer tous les deux au début
vous discuté sur skype et un jour vous
dites j'en ai ras le bol du virtuel et
vous invitez jill pour un week-end en
alsace et depuis vous n'êtes jamais
quittée en fait
je suis allé j'ai fait 600 km pour aller
rencontrer marcel et quand on s'est vus
voilà on a commencé à discuter au bout
d'une heure il m'a dit la chambre d'amis
est prête j'ai dit est ce que je peux
dormir avec toi ce soir qu'est ce qui
vous a plu chez lui son charisme oui son
charisme son humour
ses poèmes aussi parce que ce sont des
poèmes érotiques en général vont
forcément ce qu'il faut dire aussi parce
qu'on pourrait dire elle fait ça pour le
pognon c'est qu'en fait il a très peu
d'argent il a quoi 900 euros par mois
oui l'allocation adulte handicapé ouais
c'est juste que vous voulez mais quoi
c'est juste ça
vous êtes marié s'est marié 14 février
dernier rue mercière grand batteur des
prochains venu apporterait alors
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus
they do in a l'habitude abonnez vous
émettez un ce bleu